hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Doctor Who episode for video just
the second part of last week's episode
all about the idea of bootstrap
paradoxes what that is is the idea that
something can exist like information or
a person or a device before it was
created it's also a way of explaining
some of Doctor Who solutions you know
given the nature of time travel really I
kind of like the quirks of this episode
more than I like the story itself I'm
gonna go ahead and say that the first
two episodes are a better two-parter
than these two like last week's episode
presented a lot of interesting ideas I
didn't feel like the story in this
episode you know kind of went jammed
together with last week's episode formed
a better story though the whole thing is
a great satire on the nature of Doctor
Who logic you know just in the fact that
people always argue that Doctor Who
never obeys its own internal logic
especially when they want to criticize
Steven Moffat so I'll give them points
for that but just having a lot of
amazing things in an episode doesn't
necessarily make the episode amazing
itself let's do the top 5 WTF moments
and new round of the giveaway starts now
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's a $20 Amazon gift card here
we go number 5 the doctor breaks the
fourth wall and asks the question who
created Beethoven's fifth even though I
didn't give super high marks to the
episode in general I definitely give
high marks to this introduction to the
episode just like this scene with the
doctors explaining Beethoven is one of
the best things ever if you remember
last year during listen they kind of did
something like this where he had this
sweeping intro by himself he was kind of
amusing to himself about things there
been a couple other times where the
doctor has directly addressed the camp
like broken the fourth wall the fourth
doctor did it during the invasion of
time and even before that
the first doctor did it during the
Daleks master plan the whole stories
about him being a super fan of Beethoven
having all of his records original
copies of all of his sheet music in one
to go back and get them signed you know
just like a typical fan would but when
he goes back he finds out that Beethoven
never existed something happened so he
has to become Beethoven so that
Beethoven can create that music in the
first place but who created the sheet
music that the doctor has that's the
bootstrap paradox you kind of see that
theme through the episode but then he
explains it like he makes it literal at
the end where he's like I am
created the ghost to say those names
because I saw it so who created that
first ghost to give him the idea to
create the ghost you have to laugh
because they answer the question about
the ghost without actually answering the
question like they still leave it
open-ended because it's supposed to be a
paradox you're not supposed to
completely understand it in that in and
of itself is a great commentary on some
of Doctor Who's logic it's not always
supposed to make sense but on to number
four meet the tavola Undertaker alive
and well in the past his whole speech
was great like he was a very brief part
of the episode much much bigger in last
week's episode is this spooky ghost his
explanation is is that there was a race
enslaving them so the Fisher Kings race
came liberated them ended up hating the
Tivoli's so much that they went on to
enslave them and the Fisher King here is
a warlord among his people
he's like an extra-special member of his
own race on door number 3 Bennett calls
the doctor on his he changes
his rules anytime it suits him this is a
big theme in the episode the doctor not
changing the future he made it very
plain to Bennett that things would go
very very badly you know butterfly
effect is they tried to warn their past
selves especially when they were
actually in the past the doctor doesn't
necessarily correct him and even though
you know it seems like a big strike
against the doctors character like he's
he's kind of a terrible person while
also being a hero if you've been
watching Doctor Who for any amount of
time then you've seen that the doctor
always breaks his own rules all the time
so I was just kind of waiting for the
explanation to come his Redemption kind
of comes at the end when he's able to
save everyone even though it seems like
everyone would have died originally if
he hadn't have started breaking his own
rules but the problem is is that why
didn't he just go back then and save the
crew member that died the woman that
died if he was able to break all those
other rules and they had the explanation
that we don't know who created that
first ghost then why didn't they also
use that same explanation to save that
dead crew member right you know I think
that probably we just made it feel like
the episode had no stakes so maybe when
they were writing this and like okay you
know we'll have to keep this one person
dead just so it feels real normally when
things like this happen and I'm trying
to explain Doctor Who to other people
that haven't watched it before I just
explained it's kind of silly science
fiction that doesn't always obey its own
internal logic so it's not completely
supposed to make sense so
crew member dies but he's able to save
everyone else because of a paradox so
feel like sometimes you just have to
turn that part of your brain off when
you're watching on the number two the
doctor versus the Fisher King who
apparently knows all about Time Lords
the voice was actually done by Peter
Serafinowicz and they actually like to
modulate to get that crazy grating voice
they had one of the people from slit not
like the band Slipknot helped them is a
great creature in the pantheon of Doctor
Who monsters that you know I feel like
he looks pretty amazing I think it would
have been nicer to see him run around a
little bit more but I was just
fascinated at how well he knew the Time
Lords history a race of people that
found their teeth and became one of the
most warlike cultures in the universe
it's always fun to see villains or
monsters and episodes throw the
Timelords in the doctors face saying
that yeah I might be a villain but they
are also valence - and you are a villain
by proxy because you remember their race
and of course out of my number one WTF
moment what is in the box
a giant bootstrap paradox so they closed
the loop on the episode without actually
closing the loop that liked the solution
to the episode is something that's a
little unexplainable like which version
of the doctor placed the charge at the
dam to burst it and kill the Fisher King
in the episode they go back to Scotland
in the past then they tried to leave but
the TARDIS brings them back to a half an
hour before those events so is the
version of the doctor that placed the
charge of the Damned like another
version that went even further back in
the past because that dam was actually a
pretty good distance away like he would
have had to hike pretty far but just to
explain the doctor's speech with the
Fisher King that's also kind of a doctor
lies moment breeze like I've already
fixed it the writings not in my head
anymore that was the lie the writing was
definitely still inside his head the
Fisher King goes out to the crack sees
that the writing is still there so he
says the doctor lied he lied to get him
out there so that he could burst the dam
and kill the Fisher King in the hologram
itself might have even been part of
security protocol 7 1 - that's actually
from another Steven Moffat episode
security protocol 7 1 2 came from blink
so the episode was a lot of fun you know
I mean the doctor ended up being the Box
like we all kind of expected but I feel
like it still wasn't that great of an
episode overall the solution of the
problem felt like a bit of a cheat from
a writer's perspective but I did
like the way that they tied it together
so I definitely give it bonus points for
having thematic consistency from
beginning to end that's a really good
question let me know in the comments
do you like Doctor Who episodes that
don't necessarily answer the questions
that they raise on purpose they
knowingly withhold information and are
very upfront and honest about it
hopefully they don't do that two weeks
in a row because Maisie Williams episode
is next week I think she's actually in
two episodes technically it's not a
two-parter but I think it's kind of a
two-parter I know everybody is still
wondering who she is I think she's a new
character but someone who is gonna be
big in Doctor Who Canon like a
relatively powerful character and in
Steven Moffat said that he didn't
necessarily intend for her to be
recurring but I think the idea is that
Maisie Williams could always come back
on the show if she ever wanted to in
future years so new Doctor Who posting
next week be sure to subscribe to get it
and congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner
Ethan kicks you in a $20 Amazon gift
card I'll announce the winner from this
week's giveaway when I post my next
Doctor Who video just in case you guys
haven't seen New York Comic Con is
happening right now so I'm posting some
of the bigger panels I just posted the
Game of Thrones panel you can click here
to watch that and you can click here for
all my other Doctor Who videos thank you
so much for watching everybody
what's that five see you guys tonight